this is a production of Cornell
University okay
and today I'm going to talk about
QTL mapping or potato cyst nematode
resistance and to trace up to agronomic
trace in
I've performed really from research
project evaluating to merkel markers for
selecting potato system at the recent
clone and cutie analysis of new potato
cyst nematode registers and cutie
analysis of cheap coal and specific
gravity so to help you understanding I
start with introduction of potato cyst
nematode there are one of them is global
Durazo Kenzie's another one is global
they also have a common name old golden
nematode and this picture shows a
juvenile stage of the and for your
convenience for today I'm going to use
these two impulses limit or this
pathogen is a soil borne pathogen and it
has a really stable dormant stage which
is called cyst according to the one
report the nematode could survive for
over 30 years over 30 years by
maintaining this and also it is it can
be easily transferred by our management
so because of these features it's very
hard to eradicate or control these
passages in the United States the golden
limited is distributed in a new here and
a pearl cyst nematode distributed in an
idle detection of the potassium at would
always initiate crunching action and
trading embargo and this is one of the
three most serious potato passing in the
world according to the atheist if golden
tomatoes became widely prevalent without
appropriate control and your loss would
reach four point eight but I think
instead of this tax I think this picture
will dispensary it is these bags are
showing the potato yield from the non
infested field and these bags represent
potentially from infested field and you
can see it like a huge difference so
this there's a reason why I study golden
in 1941 the golden immortal was first
observed in a united state especially in
a Nassau County on a Long Island yoke
and after the first detection golden
nematode especially pastime ro one of
the golden nematode gradually appeared
in eight other counties at this moment
let me briefly explain how we can divide
into the different pests type if any
amount for example if a name I told you
take a sample from this is there are
multiple ways but the dermatologist
inoculate the tenth take the samples on
that these three different are wild
potato species and if the nematode can
survive on one plant we can put the plus
sign and if the nematode cannot survive
aware we produce we can put - so by
combining this wizard we can divide into
the multiple pencil types golden
nematode composed of five different pest
types and El Sistema toad is composed of
three different pests type and I just
want to emphasize that person Arawa has
predominant pest type for a long time
not only in many European countries but
also in a New York state so many
researchers put an effort and time to
buy raises resistance genes effective to
the dispatched type fortunately they
could find h1 gene which is very
effective against the pests at erawan it
is known to be located on a chromosome
five and the many potato breeding
program in the world using his genes was
really successful
for example Cornell breeding could
release 24 potato varieties which equal
to h1 and of course this potato various
works well to control the damage of
pests are one however there was one
drawback in a potato program when it
comes to the water basins because we
still relied on
bioassay so to reduce the amount of the
bio say maybe Markos this election is
one of a good option you know that so I
start to evaluate these two markers
which don't to be tightly linked to the
so from now on I'm going to explain how
I evaluate that to more ocular markers
or selecting our one resistance potato
closer to all 50 similar marker and GGC
pike this is one of the core of the
potato and this is known to be
resistance against the arrow one and
catalan is susceptible
Kirti burn so I use these both registers
control and susceptible control as you
can see in this picture are raisins
clump produce 450 based here PCR product
and susceptible chrome produce 1,000 500
base pair PCR product and when I tested
other breeding clones or cultivars I
could get the same result like this way
when I tested the TG 6 8 9 marker from
the race alone I could see it 114 base
pierre-pierre product and I could not
see any PCR product from the susceptible
ones because of that I also use PCA to
check the piece of quality so for your
convenience I'm going to use plus sign
for presents of the phone here when it
comes to the 57 our PCR test and I'm
going to use negative sign or presence
of the one when I talking about the 57
armor and I'm going to use plus sign for
present working base pair PCR product
when I talk about a PCR test and absence
of the this piece of work will be marked
as a negative sign so I first tested 38
potato kurta burrs and as I expected
before the markers work
quite well for example when I tested all
20 susceptible culture balls all pcs
negative wizard and when I tested 18
recent score to verse 17 obey me shows
party 57 are and 14 clones was positive
for TG 6 8 9 of course there are some
exceptions such as and over IVA and King
Harry and the word shows negative and
even though this is r1 resistance and
IVA and King Harry showed the negative
response from the TG 6 8 9 P searches
even though those are our reasons so I
suppose it is caused by the
recombination event so now I start to
talk about how I tested a corner
breeding cause my purpose was to test
whether the two markers work well in a
cone a potato breeding program or nah so
I collected 342 help reading clones and
perform the exact the same test by OSA
and two PCR tests and this table
summarized all the research as you can
see here there are multiple combination
so depending on the combination of the
research of the test and the bio say I
could divide into the 8 different cases
for example if a clump was racence in a
BIOS and show the positive research in a
57 R and the TG 6 8 9 a clone belong to
case 1 and if another Club which is
susceptible and show the negative
response from the to PCR test account
belong to case 8 so as I expected before
majority raises clone belong to keep
Swan and Buzzard is susceptible clothes
belong to case 8 8 and rest of them are
cause I believe because of the
recombination so I'm going to call from
case 2 to 7 as a mismatches for your
convenience so order to be relative
small number a 6 1
and so on but when I saw the case for
compared to the other mismatches case
for shillelagh to a higher number so I'm
going to come back in the following
slide once I test the 342 clones I also
calculated prediction positive
prediction value and negative predictive
value positive prediction barriers are
calculated by determining the percentage
of fall with the marker that were a
distance beggar a prediction values were
calculated by determining the percentage
of the potato clothes licking the marker
they were susceptible so as you can see
in this table both markers really well
especially for positive prediction this
means was used so the positive response
from the PCR test the Clones has a
really high chance to have h1 gene in it
on the other hand negative preaching was
much lower however this cannot be a big
problem for the breeding purpose because
we potato breeders just focusing on
selecting raisin scone we are not
interested in as selecting susceptible
clothes so we conclude that from this
wizard the to PCR marker 57 rtv6 8/9 can
be applied into the corner future corner
breeding program okay now let me go back
to case for game so as you can see here
even though these balls are resistance
they show negative response from the to
PCR so to figure out what happening here
I go back to the list of the case for so
second column shows a list of the case
for clones and third chrome and FORSCOM
shows
parents information of each corn and why
analyzing this table I realized that the
clone Eve 48 dish too frequently
appeared as a either male parent or a
female parent for these clones so III
Reaper form the same bio are saying that
to PCR test for
- - interestingly I could not see any
difference compared to the general our
residents club so this shows resistance
in a bioassay and also + response from
57 are and then ttcc a name so a quite
similar to the general our own race is
closed so I go back to the pedigree
information of this clone and
interesting I realized that Solon and
virtuality this is one of the wild POTUS
wild potato species and these pictures
predominantly in a pedigree of the
eforea h2 according to the dilemma at
all some accession of this wild total
species all races are won so I suppose
that all previous breeders interpret an
unknown erawan racing genes came from
the s portunity so I thought that he
forged edge to include not only h1g
others so another race is located on
another chromosome may be so in research
in those kinds of on mismatch so this is
first research project so now I'm going
to explain QTL analysis of new potato
cyst nematode you put a cyst nematode
resistance as I mentioned before
first-time Arawa have been predominant
pestle for a long time in New York State
however in 1995 the new pastime r2 was
first discovered in the Stephan count in
the New York and the problem was that
the 18 races is not effective against
our - there's a reason why I started QT
analysis of our own two registers for
this analysis for this research project
I prepared 36 population which came from
the cross between and I want 21 and
these two parents are Otto tetraploid
potatoes and both of them are
heterozygous potato
and and I want to and one is r1
resistance and n I'm 115 is a lot too
susceptible for QTL mapping I use 182
protein for genotyping I use a
circumcision this is quite useful too
because this is composed of eight
thousand three hundred three snip
position so I can have a higher chance
to find some future position or so
reference for each sniffs are available
from the spool database so you can find
the location of specification such as
chromosome number physical position and
also a short description for related
genes so after scanning the DNA sample
of the white 36 population with
dissociative I could get the raw data
which is called para score or a terrible
you fellows quiz like a number so I have
to trim transform from Farah score to
general genotype data such as a AAA or a
a a B a a B D and so on so as after
transforming the genotype data I load on
a one software which is called
tetraploid slim and tetrapods new map is
specially designed for QTL analysis of
photo tetraploid so after loading the
Selective slim marker on a dis software
as we can imagine the order markers are
mixed to each other and through the
clustering function belong to this
software I could collect
steam markers which are on the same
chromosome so a potato are composed of
12 chromosomes so each circle represent
each cause in this case so through the
ordering step I could rearrange that the
selected marker which are on the same
chromosome in an order like this way and
then through the fading step I could
decide which of the four home allows
each marker which I relies on like this
way at this point
unlike the diploid cutie analysis like a
generative process
some manual process are necessary for
fading in the auto tetraploid QT
analysis so compared to the diploid
unisys these process take more time so
after completing I could get linkage map
this is one of the example of the
linkage map since I cross the two
heterozygous parents I could draw two
different sets of genetic map in this
case home alone one two four represent
for home loss of the NI 121 and home
alone five to eight represent for
homeowners of the ni 115 and left side
representing the genetic male all shapes
markers are combined at this point I'm
going to share the challenges that I
encountered while performing the Auto
tetraploid QTL mapping unlike the
general of people oilskin calling
tetraploid sim cooling a little bit
difficult let me share one example if a
cow in this case the graph showing the
ferrous core value so x axis represent
ferrous score from zero to one and you
don't need to worry about Y axis in this
case because these y axis relates you to
the polity so if a clone has an AAA age
you know type generally the clone
centered on zero and if another clone
has a a a a B it calls general centered
on 2025 and if another clone has a AABB
the clone centered on 0.5 and so on so
if the clones are well distributed like
the first example you can easily assign
appropriate genotype for each clone
however look at the disk as you can see
here even though there are multiple
cluster it's not easy to assign
appropriate you know so I spent a lot of
time for like a best or appropriate you
know assigning best
genotype so I was I have been struggling
for a long time but fortunately in 2017
Jeffrey released a new our package
called The Closer Pole and I can
overcome these difficulties or so before
the Tetra piscina that I use for
security analysis
there was only one software which is
called
tetraploid actually this is previous
version of the tetra place a map and it
has a lot of limitation or one of the
one example would be the number of the
same market that I can use only less
than 50 slim markers can be used for
each cause and if I rely on this that
means I I can lose many many chance to
find significant shipping so before then
I could not find a significant future
people but once I started use tetra
persian releasing it I could find
significant future
Hicks relate you to the arrow to
resistance and finally there are still
many all steps are doing the links map
so as I mentioned before compared to the
deployed general deployed GTO mapping
what a tetraploid gto mapping takes more
time so thanks to the newly released
softwares I could get the excellent
genome coverage in my case I could
select 2061 3 markers to cover 12
chromosomes and as you can see here
Seaver 100 markers can cover each
chromosome that means I can have a
higher chance to find choose your pick
and look at the map coverage as you can
see here majority of them's are covered
by the same markers or I like a 99% so
as a reason I could get really excellent
genome coverage this picture shows us a
marker that I use the green color
represents a marker segregated in a ni
115 and where the color represent the
same marker segregate on ni 121 and
black color represent same marker
segregate in both parents
and as you can see here same markers
well distributed across the chromosome
okay now to complete the QTL mapping I
had to blow the field tech data on the
Tetra person in map so I'm going to
explain how I measure the potentiometer
resistance after I prepare the y 36
population I planted into each pot in a
greenhouse and then after two weeks
later I inoculate eight thousand bags
into each pot like this way and then
kept going for ten weeks once the plants
start to wilt I transfer all soil and
plant material into paper bag and hey
wait for one month or drying period once
the old samples are completely dried the
samples are transferred to the fennec
for now he's a silver color fun family
especially designed for separating cysts
from the dirt so with a high-pressure
water and this funnel I could separate
this from the dirt and plant matures the
collected sees were couched under the
microscope like this way so as I
mentioned before this by us it takes a
lot of time for example I have to I had
to spend three months is for growing and
inflation and another one months for
drank beer and based on one labor force
pending funnel process can be performed
only for twenty to twenty-five cents per
day and counting process can be
performed less than 20 samples per day
so in my case I use them for replication
so I had to grow around like eight
hundred sixty samples in a greenhouse so
as your readers to whole process I had
to use around like a one year so as you
can see here reducing this pile say
about it's really important for
selecting memo to recess
after getting the fee note original
phenotype data I transformed to the bow
10 because or you know a phenotype they
asked you toward the right side too much
once I transform I could get the
distribution close to the normal
distribution and I load this data on the
teacher person in the two pairs located
here and here
and this is the wall of example the Qt
oh man especially chromosome 5 to tell
map and in this case x axis represent
the genetic map position you need
centimorgan and y axis represent low
score and we found the two significant
significant to TIA pics on clothes on
5:26 centimorgan with the lowest scores
13.4 and the second-largest future pics
at 59 centimorgan with a low score 6.6
and it's the worker mention before I was
really happy with getting this picture
because I spend around like a 5 to 6
years to see this picture so actually
when I get this one I complain about
taking a lot of time and while
discussing the worth of an even worth it
we was getting this picture
so actually QT losses was completed here
however we was wondering whether this
represent previously known Nemo 2 with
resistance genes or not I suspect that
this would represent h1g because the h1
gene is known to be eastern end of the
long arm of the chromosome 5 and also I
suspect this gene represent a disc
YouTube big represent TRP Onegin because
JP 1 gene is known to be racist suppose
all the nematode and a pulse is limited
as well as it is also located on a
chromosome 5 so to characterize these
two QTL pigs I added two additional
tests one of them is PCR test with a
57-ton marker so basically I performed a
PCR test or by 36 population with a
57-ton marker which is known to be
linked to the h1 gene and then I use the
piece year we served as a phenotype data
or tetra prism or so I could map the
location of 57 R or I can say h1 gene or
so thanks to the support of the doctor
Dan join in a universal Idol I could
achieve the Jeep elevations data of the
the same mapping population wide 36 so I
also load this and this is a wizard so
the second picture shows our two races
and third picture shows fifty seven or
eight and the last picture shows cheap
holiday raisins chutiya pa tooth
solution to Slayer 3 means a mixture or
pass type two and three so when I check
the location as you can sit here
it was located which is very close to
the second pick of the hour to distance
and when I check the Jeep a little
resistance future pick it was perfectly
matched with the most significant
significant shooter pic of the arrow to
business so from these videos I also
confirmed that these second life your
pig represent each one gene and this
future pig represent GRP one because as
I mentioned before geography one GRP one
gene is known to be racist
both olden a metal and hell cyst
nematode
and also I thought that h1 gene appears
to provide some races against our two
presumably due to the presence of the
low percentage ro1 in our two population
I just want to mention at this point is
that originally our to obtain from the
field which he initially infested with
Esther our one so the original our two
samples mixed with a small amount of the
r1 so I suppose it may be a twenty
nurse' works for this study but further
analysis of course should be following
to clarify
so I also checked a percent of bears
explained at each position when I check
the our two races at the 2016 theme
organ I'm going to call for convenience
ro to a it shows 24% percent of bears
experience it's quite high and when I
check the GPL resistance you ticket here
which I'm going to use P a 2/3 a and
this also show 9.2 percent of bears
explained also dams are quite
significant and when I take this
position our two basins pick at here I'm
going to call our to be and these are
such explained 13 so also them seem to
be really important position or our two
reasons
and based on the information provided by
the Tetra placed in May I marked a
two-tail position on the genetic map so
as I mentioned before Homo I want to
four represent one and five to eight
represent for homes and then 115 and as
you can see here ro to a and our PA to
3/8 or oval at each other and when I
check the ro to be and location both
stems are almost the same location as
well as same home alone 3 and 6 so I
also support the idea that this area
include ERP 1g and these two areas
include h1 actually this is redundant or
extra research project but for double
checking these two position I also
perform that she was the with the
software released by the Jeff endermans
group our our our blog and she was
pulley so basically I use the exactly
same marker data and the phenotype data
and as you can sit here
both of them's are perfectly matched
because the top picture shows
a genetic map that I developed before so
the most coldest sneak marker was c2 503
one and the most closely marker 259
centimorgan was C 2 4 5 4 3 6 5 and as
you can see here when I checked a few
out when I checked up 57 to tear through
the G was the the most significant
future people okay Don a slim marker c2
5 or 360 which is perfectly matching
with this one
and when I checked the r2 resistance
there were two peak and when I check
their location this one matches with the
Disney marker and this one matches with
Disney marker so his G was study also
support the idea that these two
positions are really important for our
two registers so based on these measures
our left decide to develop diagnostic
marker actually shooting she's a lab
technician yeah laughs oh let it develop
1 caps marker H oh she start from the C
to 5 and when she tested the newly
designed marker with the some several
reasons contraceptive clones now at this
point the results are well matched so we
are going to test more clones not only
in Europe breeding controllers in other
states such as Idol we try to apply the
newly designed caps marker into the
corner breeding program okay
I'm going to star the Cutie of cheap
color and the specific gravity these two
traits are really important in a potato
chipping industry because the lighter
color potato chip if you guys open the
lace you can see really white color from
the chips those colors are really
preferred by America so whenever we do
the breeding program we wanted to select
lighter potato chip color or so
specifically important since it is
always related to starch content and
starch density so this reason why I
perform this research project with the
same population that I used in a new
motor which is nematode study so I use
the same mapping population wide
pharisee population the two parents
shows I could color by especially and I
was is extremely light or chip color
compared to the other curricular so this
is quite useful clone for selecting or
developing chip chipping potato and in
this case I use the 195 cones or two TL
nemesis now I'm going to explain how I
measure the chip : the specific gravity
for measuring a chip color I use nine
scale this is one two three and this is
nine and to measure the specific gravity
I use this equation weight in air /
weight in air - weight in water and I
have measure during four years from 2010
to 2013 so when I am targeting the
phenotype data I calculate the process
heritability for each trait and as you
can see it here both of them shows well
to be higher purity abilities chip color
was coin or unlike a7 and specific race
is 0.75 and after that I transform the
original phenotype data to the below
there are a couple of reasons first of
all the original field data does not
show really good no more
so once i transformed to the blob is
much better no more distribution like
this way or so when I tested when I
perform the Qt analysis we the original
phenotype data I couldn't not see the Qt
of pics which he consistently showed
showed up on our same position
well after I transformed the blob I
could see many qts which he showed up on
the same position on the same chromosome
so I suppose it may be those are because
of the G by E effect so by transforming
to the block I could more focus on
genetic effect so after getting the blob
data I could I can compare first of all
across the year and also I can compare I
checked the correlation between a chip
color and the specific gravity so as you
can see in this table there is no big
difference between two years when I see
the specific gravity all correlations
around like a nine so really there's no
difference and even though chip color
shows little to be smaller collation
compared to specifically but steer is
quite high or most of them shows over
seven a point seven so I couldn't not
see huge difference across the year and
when I check the correlation between
chip color and the specific gravity I
could see a negative correlation even
though the value itself is relatively
small but this is quite good sign for
the potato peeler a breather because if
we if a breeders focus on lighter color
that means we can have a chance to
select the higher specific gravity which
is preferred by the potato chip company
as well at the same time so I think this
is quite good sign for reading proposed
and then I found a lot of QTL pics from
the many multiple chromosomes in this
case
PC represent chip color and number
number 2010
represent the phenotype data from each
year as I mentioned before I measure a
phenotype area on in 2010 11 12 and 13
so these represent each year and there's
all all miss I could get after I get I
transformed to the blood data I could
get five different set of data for
represent each year 2010 to 2013 and
last one what last one last blood
dataset was obtained by pulling all
finitary
across the four years so in this case
over preserve the blood data obtained by
pulling all you know that they're all
across the four years so from this table
I first of all I could fall significant
QT on chromosome 1 3 4 5 6 7 8 10 and 12
there Allah and interesting in common on
3 4 7 shows the future piece which
consistently appear appeared on same
podium or very close position and also
in this case the solely here represent
acute here making darker color and
hollow scale represent the qtr making
lighter color yeah and this shows where
the cutie cutie of pics okay among the
four kimonos so
I see the chromosome seven there was
largest cute here for cheap color
especially home alone seven which came
from the NI 115 of course and this
explained 13% of the Bears expect
explained for four years so I think this
is quite important future or future a
chip color selection and here here to
cover genes
chuco's phosphate synthesis and plasma
membrane proton proton ATPase located
within a one loyal support interval for
this acutely when I checked out criminal
three there was a binary Teochew color
located at 6770 Morgan and a putative
invertase in Heber gene is located about
one point be away from this cutie ax
this table showed the future pic of the
specific gravity SG represent specific
gravity and rest all terms are same and
in this case arrow head toward the
downside represent lowering lowering
specific gravity and the arrow head
toward the upside represent making the
QTL making or increasing the specific
gravity and while analyzing I realized
that comes from two three four five and
eight shows the qtp which appeared on
the same question or very close position
each other
why analyzing the table I found that on
the chromosome for the most significant
cutie pics exist at the Year twenty
eight centimorgan
explaining sixty six point four to
eleven percent of the Bears explain
depending on the year and a gene
including phosphofructokinase is about
two hundred thousand base pair away from
the cheetah picks just intact playing
portal or and basically control the
first commuted step of the glycolysis
respiration so as a starch content to
represent the amount of the starchy
synthesis less the amount of the
respired away for
this gene become like a really
interesting candidate for this cutie on
chromosome 2 has a single QTL at the 72
centimorgan and ik India team glucose
6-phosphate dehydrogenase is met or like
a 500,000 base fare from the target GTL
and close on five verses showed us - QT
at the 31 centimorgan a gene coding for
starch granule bond ro one protein is
located 300,000 base pair from the disk
ETOP
and silently silencing this gene is not
to increase the starch level in a in a
in ellipse so I think for future stress
security selection so let me summarize
this whole presentation as I mentioned
before these two markers can be used for
cornea breeding program and QTL at the
6070 morgan 2680 morgan of the condom 5
comfort races - both are o2 and our PA
2/3 pass type and heo engine appears to
provide some resistance against our o2
principal will get you the presence of
the low percentage that are along in our
population and cheap : specific grades
were highly heritable and multiple
future pick for cheek color detected on
comment on 3 & 7
notable feature picks for specific rows
were observed on chromosome 2 4 & 5 so
this offer today and I just want to
appreciate my community member thank you
for water long story make sure that
thank you for your patience and I
appreciate science encouragement she
always encouraged me to start no like a
used research for there were interest in
research projects so we really
appreciate it
a rolling come on give me a lot of other
work ties about a device is otherwise is
about international agriculture because
I really interested in a international
pretty especially reducing
the hunger problem and he gave me a lot
of good suggestions appreciate it and I
appreciate this is my members and they
helped me a lot to practice presentation
and they do the research project and
technicians are amazing because these
guys are works really well and so called
me Allah so I appreciate shipping and
math and also Michael Missouri and gave
me a chance to do the TA at first along
so I appreciate because of his he gave
me a chance I I could practice
especially like I couldn't get the
teaching experience and Darlene help me
practice I appreciate it and their needs
help me a lot for statistical analysis
so I learned a lot of important static
statistical methods from him and I'm a
mythology like salami alike since I did
not have any experience in Animoto logic
and the mythology but she an effusion so
for me to do the experiments so I learn
a lot from them and also Michigan group
so for me a lot for genotyping and do
the Qt analysis and also Lewis help me
to get cheap a little data so without
her support I could not complete this
research project and Chrismukkah she's a
software developer she developed a
terrible sin man and she's a lot of
American research actually she stayed in
a Scotland but she frequently visit the
US and they communicate with the many
American researcher and she also helped
me a lot and also Jeffrey and them I
helped me to do the she was analysis so
finally I appreciate on a whole connect
committee because you know I was not
like a super smart student when I came
to here first but
the corner come you changed me a lot
whenever I go to the conference I have a
really how can say that feels like I'm
really nice quite funny story but you
know it's amazing
so I appreciate thank you for listening
my presentation thanks which is the
reservation I have in uses mark each one
resistance is that Ernie I was in
primary primary gene his species that
was used in the breeding program or I
hate and it was so major effort we're in
high resistance before the h1 gene was
identified and managed so there's
there's a lot of claims but we were
using the bio as our resistance we kept
out resistance yes hmm
I think this kind of simplicity 800 AMA
nated but I'm afraid that when he throw
away the marker all posted not have a
mod that are resistant
without the light that's not a sexual
actions with each one and we won't take
them out wait and I wait I didn't
realize was all the items and we so yeah
you're right
a children originated from the Solano
and me Gina he's faced a CPC one six
seven so according to my knowledge at
least almost all breeding program to use
their specific clone as solanum and
these you know CPC 167 three so I think
the agency that we have and bird espana
there's another one there's also known
to have each one gene but again
the case for yeah the case for yeah I
cannot clearly what happened in these
calls but worker and I while discussing
we suppose it may because as I mentioned
as a fertility going to the one European
report so maybe another races is located
on another chromosome effect our one
races yeah but I actually I don't know
yeah what happened Eva Eva Eva has
actually I believe that Eva has H one
gene but interesting
[Music]
so TLC mm-hmm you try to use all the
markers on regression problems in that
College disclaimer we're set
no general lack that way of course
technically we can calculate for each
marker but it takes a lot of time
frankly speaking so that's the software
the tetraploid my software always
provide QTL actually he asked about did
I calculate percent of barriers
explained for each marker am i right so
I can say I I want to say that I didn't
but I don't need to do let me explain it
so in the Tetra poison my software
always provide the most significant
future fix for each chromosome so once I
put appropriate genetic genotype data
and the phenotype data this number and
where America we showed on the screen
however if you really want to calculate
other position for example if you want
to know how much this percent of beerus
explained you have to make a like a kind
of like a linear model for taking out
some clones which has a alleles relate
you to this because if you keep all
population to calculus one does not show
percent of Barracks explained for this
always shows the most significant q-tip
its own so
I can say that really I have to explain
all the long story I mean you have to
develop a linear model and then figure
out which clones are related to this one
which which code is now related to the D
so once you found the cause and then you
have to rewrote the whole QT analysis so
really complicating or so 24 is
extremely high whenever I do the qtls
for other traits so I guarantee the
other area has a really small percent of
various it's almost predictable yeah so
maybe that you don't take the first I'll
use it like that it kinda like a
phenotype yeah okay yeah so your
comments is really useful as well as
it's possible but I just want to
emphasize that I work in a potato
breeding especially we have a specific
reading purpose so we are only
interested in a position which is most
related to the target trait so even
though maybe other area would be related
who is playing small amount of variance
but for the breeding purpose those are
so we just focus on the two significant
utilities thank you again
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu